all right so the news seems pretty good
if you ask me you got a booming economy
and employment still dropping a new
Supreme Court judge who can actually
stay awake peace is breaking out in the
Koreas an American pastor is released
from Turkey and I just saw Michael a
vanetti
downtown selling pencils he's so
adorable in cardboard shorts yep
in two years Trump solved more headaches
than a boatload of buffering so what are
the polls saying and should you believe
them I believe in pulse only the ones
that have us up because they're the only
honours yes I think that made sense
so all this great news can mean just one
road for the media keep looking for the
bad no matter how far back you gotta go
check out this headline from The
Hollywood Reporter about Donald Trump's
senior policy adviser Stephen Miller
hill of love this miller's third-grade
teacher says he was a loner and ate glue
holy seriously that's a real headline
yeah apparently Miller would dry glue
and eat it
meaning Miller was just like every other
third grader now the teachers been
suspended for leaking this valuable info
I hope she's home right now making a
scrapbook with a bottle of Elmer's by
her side but you but you know who's
worse The Hollywood Reporter seriously
how far have you strayed from your
mission as a movie industry rag to do
this story how is eating glue Hollywood
news I can't wait to see your next scoop
as an unborn baby Mike Pompeo once
kicked his mom right in the womb daddy
how much you want to bet the teachers a
Democrat as well as the reporter and the
editor their hatred is so irrational
that any behavior is permitted just ask
the pantsuit you cannot be civil with a
political party that wants to destroy
what you stand for what you care about
now that's funny
I don't seem to remember her being civil
to Monica Juanita or Paula and is this
the right time for her to lecture us on
civility her party just ruined a man and
she tells us were uncivil that's like
running over my dog then billing me for
the burial
by the way by the way Hillary and Bill
are going on a tour together
she wants to make money and he wants to
make it to the letter R in his little
black book she wants to pay for the
second renovation of their third home he
wants to have a foursome with triplets
and a duplex that creates 24 different
combinations and you can bet Bill's
already done the math so now it's about
which sides more uncivil if you bring up
the laugh the Lib scream what about
Trump you so mean so my job today is to
compare uncivil behaviors of the left
and the right so first the left
you got the Scalise shooting you got
post-election riots you got campus
speech shut down so you got an T far
remember Madonna and then it was Johnny
Depp there are people chased from
restaurants yet Kathy Griffin you had
mobs chanting about wanting dead cops
that is a lot it's not a bug in the
system that's the whole damn system so
what do we have on the right
this guy licking Dianne Feinstein
Pocahontas sleepy Joe Biden crooked
Hillary fake news
daaang dick sleepy eyes sleeping you son
of a [ __ ] she'll tell you so is Kratz
he's ruff he's rude
but it's no comparison it's just words
yeah once in a while we do get a wacko
doing wacko
but our fringe stays fringe we don't
have them over for dinner but the Dems
have a bigger problem their party is
riddled with hateful factions trying to
scare you into accepting their demands I
call them a mob but then the media might
collapse Ted Cruz getting chased out of
restaurants by a mob you're not gonna
use them oh it's it's totally a mob put
up a mob stop stop that is mob behavior
Matt we already did that we already said
they weren't mobs if it were Tea
Partiers we'd call it a mob for sure
come on let's be serious let me let me
let me move past the M word the M word
now it's the M word it's funny though
how they respond in sync it's almost
like an M word look when you enable
groupthink as an unbending intimidating
force you get a mob it's not new
left-wing belief is based on marrying
the personal to the political in order
to mobilize then demonize and if they
consider you evil they're justified in
doing this
aren't you you just know that guy lives
on someone's couch and he has an entire
microbial civilization living in his
pants so what's his wife know he's Mike
that's just one of his problems maybe
all of this good news is making these
people nuts
perhaps they need to take it out on
something hey Tom you go into the
protest this weekend ah I'm out I just
can't miss another one of Cynthia's
games maybe next time yeah don't get me
wrong I'm an angry liberal but I'm
exhausted I mean he just keeps winning I
wish there was an easier way to fight
back there is now with rage pillow the
first pillow that reminds you that
things are getting done even if you
don't like it just squeeze it and let
all your frustrations out no thanks to
you the rage pillow is so convenient you
can take it anywhere get angry at the
office hi thanks for holding I was on
another call at a restaurant
have to check even at the movies order
now we'll throw in the blow-up pilot
from airplane you want to take back the
house you got to take back your life
first with rage pillow
[Music]
warning tearing the tag off the pillow
is still a crime because America is
totally over regulated
that's welcome tonight yet whenever you
are youtubing look for dave rubin
creator in a host you can steal that of
the rubin report dave rubin she's so
bright lighthouses look for her in a
storm her new book is called hash tag do
not disturb author and TV host Jedediah
Peola she's trim grim and light of limb
natural review reporter Kat Tim the
Eiffel Tower is this towel rack former
WWE Superstar and my massive sidekick
Cyrus alright alright Dave you're a
classical liberal I you are so I'm going
to turn you into our what's wrong with
your party question what's going on
well first off did I hear that correctly
that was leaking Diane conjures up two
different kinds of leaks what are your
thoughts look this was the this was what
was gonna happen if you ran around for
years screaming that every one of you
guys and you evil people on Fox we're
all racists and bigots and homophobes of
course the end game was going to be that
you'd end up using violence against
these people and condoning it and that's
thing in Portland it's like these guys
they call themselves an tyfa yeah
they're the foie there are the fact is
they literally dress like soldiers cobra
soldiers from GI Joe they're the good
guy yeah something is seriously wrong I
like that they self-appointed themselves
as crossing guards yeah that's like
that's the first step yeah but also it
is it's a type of mental disorder to be
a white person screaming at another
white person over his whiteness yes
that's a modern mental disorder Tyrus I
saw you practically leap out of your of
your comfortable chair when you heard
that when you heard em word in a second
oh why people attacking each other
M words the new N word yet has never
been a better time to be black like I've
never seen a white guy talk to a white
guy like that that's hurtful like that's
that sucks for him to be white and be
talked to like that by another white
whiter guy actually like what is that
white on white it's white on white
violence it's like bad right it's
terrible man I feel bad for those guys
and it's amazing that they always I
never have those issues in a crosswalk
never someone say hey go this way or
turn that way they always pick the yeah
and the guy looks a little well like you
little bit I know I know where you're
going I know where you're going it's
okay they seize all the steering wheel
let's go pick on that kid he's height
shaming you are height shaming no I'm
car shaming they need to make higher
seats never happen to me but you were
making a great point and now I forgot
what it was oh it had to do with what
they okay so these two Netflix employees
chased Brian Kilmeade
right he was at this it was leaving his
agent they chased him down to a subway
then they went into the subway and they
they incited the people in the subway to
target him they won't do that to you
Tyrus but they'll do it to kill me
especially if they chased me into subway
because I'm luring them the doors closed
that's your ass
Jedidiah I will defend people who are
out of power for their desire to express
rage but it seems like the left is
always expressing rage whether they're
in or out of power yeah they're always
mad about something yes you can express
rage but you can't destroy property you
can't go out there everyone always talks
and defends the First Amendment I defend
the First Amendment too but you can't go
out there and destroy businesses you
can't get in people's faces in
restaurants and drive them out of spaces
that I hate to break it to CNN that is
the definition of a mom a bunch of
people that make your life and it's it's
so crazy to me because you're seeing
these people in most media outlets
reveal themselves to be exactly who they
really are you have anchors that are
supposed to be moderating the debate and
they're so mad and so defensive because
Trump won and they're still mad about it
and now they have to defend this mob
that they're compelled to jump in and
actually they're on the partisan side
now they're not playing anchor anymore
they're not moderating if they're all
berating talk about the teacher but do
you have thoughts about the mob or would
you like to discuss the third grade
teacher I can discuss whatever you want
I'm very versatile why don't you pick
surprise me well I can do both quickly
okay please do I can say first of all no
judge ease on eating glue yes when I was
a child I used to love to eat the
delicious rock salts that they used to
melt the snow yes yes and I was actually
quite popular in the first grade as for
the mob mentality it wasn't just Hillary
Clinton this week it was also Eric
Holder saying when they go low we kick
them yeah not only is that not nice
that's also not very effective because
if I am on the ground and someone is
kicking me I'm not going to be thinking
gee I would love to thoughtfully
consider this person use on health care
and immigration I'm thinking why is this
kicking me yes
and so if they really want to actually
have these meaningful dialogues about
issues and actually make a change then
you have to be civil yeah yeah we got to
move on but I'm still I don't understand
somebody from The Hollywood Reporter
call me and tell me why you would do
that story when you're called The
Hollywood Reporter and you're a movie
industry Journal I don't understand it I
mean if only there was a story about a
producer who's been raping people for 25
years maybe that would be a story that
The Hollywood Reporter could have
covered